a la 1 y 23 de la madrugada del 26 de
abril de 1986 el reactor número 4 de la
planta nuclear de chernóbil explotó una
nube radiactiva cubrió el cielo la
central vladimir ilich lenin situada en
la actual frontera entre ucrania y
belarús era una de las instalaciones
nucleares en las que la antigua unión
soviética había invertido más dinero
instalando cuatro reactores de bbk que
ocurrió en el punto más radiactivo del
planeta el 25 de abril los trabajadores
de chernóbil querían probar si uno de
los reactores se enfriaba en caso de que
la central se quedara sin electricidad
pero no cumplieron los protocolos de
seguridad incrementando la potencia de
la planta cuando intentaron apagarlo se
generó otro aumento de potencia
provocando explosiones en cadena en su
interior el techo de la central voló por
los aires y el núcleo quedó expuesto
esparciendo inmensas cantidades de
material radiactivo por todo el
hemisferio norte de la tierra como esta
mañana de abril y los días posteriores
el viento no dejó de soplar hacia el
norte el 70% de las secuelas radiactiva
se aterrizaron en belarús los bomberos
intentaron todo para apagar el incendio
más de medio millón de civiles y
militares fueron reclutados en la
entonces unión soviética como los
llamados liquidado
para limpiar y contener la lluvia
radiactiva por orden del entonces líder
soviético mijail gorbachov quien intentó
silenciar y minimizar la tragedia del 28
de abril bajo presión anunciaron lo
ocurrido
chernóbil fue según el expresidente ruso
uno de los principales clavos en el
ataúd de la urss que colapsó en 1991 a
tres kilómetros de la planta se
encontraba la que hoy es una ciudad
fantasma prípiat de casi 50 mil
habitantes las autoridades tardaron 36
horas en evacuar a los habitantes de la
región
la catástrofe cuyas secuelas siguen
todavía visibles en la vida de miles de
personas ocasionó la muerte inmediata de
31 trabajadores de la planta y bomberos
centenares de personas resultaron
heridas y unas cuatro mil podrían morir
más tarde como consecuencia de la
exposición a la radiación unas cifras
que aún siguen generando disputas si
bien la región atrae el turismo es un
desierto de edificios abandonados donde
ahora 35 años después la naturaleza
salvaje se abre paso entre las ruinas el
peor accidente nuclear de la historia